the movie is set in 1862 and it revolves
around Elizabeth lib right she is an
English nurse who is sent to a tiny
Irish village to observe an 11 year old
girl named Anna O'Donnell Anna's family
has made an unbelievable claim that she
has not consumed any food since the last
four months yet she is perfectly healthy
and fine given the cost of my recent
grocery bills I too would love to know
how Anna does it in the first scene lib
arrives in Ireland and makes her way
into a lodge where she will stay for the
entirety of her visit the next day she
is taken to a place where the village
committee is waiting for her lib learns
that she will be assisted in her
Endeavor by a religious nun named sister
Michael the committee consists of a
medical practitioner a priest and some
other important people of the town the
meeting starts and lib and sister
Michael are instructed to keep watch on
the girl Anna with the help of routine
8-hour shifts for two weeks on the 14th
day they are to report their findings to
the committee members which will finally
reveal if Anna has supernatural
abilities before ending the meeting the
committee also warns lib and sister
Michael to not confer with each other
about the case afterwards lib travels to
the O'Donnell residence with the medical
practitioner Dr mcbriarty which lies on
the outskirts of the village there lib
meets the extremely religious family of
Anna which consists of her parents and
older sister Kitty it turns out the
little girl receives visitors from all
parts of the country who are Keen to
witness her Miracle after the visitors
leave I mean leave lib oh gosh after the
visitors leave lib goes upstairs and
finds Anna in a healthy state but
strangely the little girl keeps on
praying after every hour as if she is
asking for something when asked a better
secret Anna claims that she consumes
Mana from Heaven to remain alive
according to the Bible Mana is an edible
substance which God apparently used to
distribute later at dinner lib notices a
family photograph which also includes a
young man on inquiring she learns that
he was lib's elder brother who passed
away a few years ago due to a mysterious
illness the same night before going to
bed lib is seen taking some kind of
liquid hallucinogen which she keeps in a
small pocket along with some baby boots
after taking the supposed drug she
pricks her finger draws blood from it
and then licks it she does this every
night before sleeping in order to cope
with her stress and past traumas which
are not specified but probably have to
do with being some sort of vampire
hippie the next day lib takes Anna out
into the fields for a walk before
examining her room to check if there are
any places which can be used to hide
food however she doesn't find anything
suspicious while leaving lib expresses
her concern to Dr mcbrearty about the
large number of visitors that Anna gets
she asserts that for a serious study
Anna needs some quiet and isolation to
which the doctor agrees the following
morning while having breakfast lib meets
a guy named William Byrne a local man
who now works as a journalist for the
Daily Telegram in London William
mentions that he's been sent by the
company to interview the miracle girl
Anna however Liv informs him that Anna
is not taking visitors from now on as
per the doctor's request later at the
O'Donnell household lib chats within his
sister Kitty and learns that the last
thing Anna had eaten was wheat and bread
it turns out that it was on her 11th
birthday that night as lib is keeping
watch over the little girl she fiddles
around with one of her toys and
accidentally breaks it surprisingly she
finds a lock of hair inside which is
revealed to be of Anna's late brother
the next morning lib apologizes for
breaking the toy and proceeds to strike
up a friendly conversation with the
hopes of establishing a friendship with
the young girl she does so by giving her
a pet name man before introducing her
own name in the afternoon lib helps
Santa dress up and takes her out for a
walk the latter slowly becomes
accustomed to her new friend and starts
opening up from their conversation we
get to know lib had served in the
Crimean War she saw many soldiers suffer
and die and this is why she experiences
bouts of depression at times however
despite this lib says that she feels
very privileged to be with people even
when they die on the way back home Anna
stumbles upon William who is still in
town due to his boss's daily demand for
information regarding the miracle child
here's a headline Willy boy shove it up
your ass he presses lib for information
and the latter finally reveals that
nothing but water has passed through
Anna's lips in the past few days however
William doesn't believe it and calls the
whole thing a hoax as the days pass lib
notices something strange every night
before bed Anna's family prays with her
and the mother even kisses her mouth as
part of the ritual suspecting that it
has something to do with the whole case
one day lib banishes the family from
getting in contact with Anna she lies
that it is a requirement of the watch as
per Dr mcbriarty's orders the family
becomes very distressed because of the
new rule surprisingly the very next day
Anna's Health begins to decline possibly
because of the lack of nutrition in her
body lib informs the journalist William
about it and the two decide to wait
until something conclusive comes up the
same day as lib carries out her regular
inspection and checkup of Anna she finds
out that the little girl's teeth are
decaying and that one has already fallen
out on her way back home Liv meets
Anna's sister Kitty and the two strike
up a conversation Kitty reveals that she
and William were once close friends
before he was sent to school in England
he studied for years and returned but by
that time his entire family had perished
due to the Great Famine hearing this a
shocked lib returns to the lodge and
tries to comfort William one thing leads
to another and the two end up having
coitus I wonder if they also drank each
other's blood the next morning as the
two talk about their past Liv reveals
that she had previously given birth
however just after two weeks the baby
died and her husband disappeared soon
after this is the main reason she
decided to leave for the Crimea War
later in the afternoon lib takes Anna
out for a walk and introduces him to
William the little girl is skeptical
about the meeting but William eventually
wins her trust by giving her a
thamatrope toy unfortunately that
evening Anna's well-being gets even
worse so lib requests her parents give
her something to eat however they refuse
to do so claiming that Anna had
previously sworn to never eat again left
with no choice lib heads over to Dr
mcbriarty's office and explains the
situation to him she requests that he
convinced the committee to stop the
watch but Dr mcbriarty refuses he claims
that Anna is converting sunlight into
energy and so they have nothing to worry
about before the meeting ends he orders
lib to do her job which is only to keep
watch and not to diagnose Anna anymore
one day during her shift lib is unable
to see Anna suffer and becomes desperate
to save her as a result she goes
downstairs and asks for a bowl of soup
for herself lib then proceeds to force
feed Anna by shoving a tube down her
throat however when the little girl
continues to cry and Revolt she realizes
her mistake and withdraws the tube at
this point Anna has started having
difficulties in breathing celeb Comforts
her and profusely apologizes a few hours
later William and lib take Anna out for
a walk hoping that the fresh air can
cure her ailment as they wander around
the beautiful landscape William informs
lib that he has already submitted his
report titled Murder By degrees in which
he blames Anna's expected death on her
own family and on the community he then
proceeds to explain the contents but
just then Anna has trouble breathing and
faints on the spot panicked lib quickly
carries her back to the house while
William Retreats home as he cannot be
seen with Anna as per the committee
rules for the watch after further
inspection lib finds out that Anna's
lungs have collapsed which has resulted
in her constant coughing without proper
medical intervention she is not going to
last even for a week the next morning as
a distraught lib is having breakfast in
her Lodge she goes into a deep state of
thought and finally deduces O'Donnell's
tricks wasting no time she then makes
her way to the house and confronts Anna
libis found out that the Mana from
Heaven which Anna refers to is actually
chewed up food that her mom feeds her
while they kiss during their daily
prayers this means that the little girl
has been eating all along but she is
oblivious to it because of the constant
brainwash she experiences day in and day
out Anna believes that the shoot up food
is actually a gift from God I thought
the kisses just tasted like food however
when living forms her about the truth
Anna finally realizes that she has been
duped she then goes on to disclose the
reasons for her fasting it's revealed
that her late brother had often
mistreated her in the past their parents
knew about this but didn't do anything
to intervene instead after the evil
brother passed away from a mysterious
illness they blamed his death on Anna
now they are forcing her to pray every
day so that the evil brother can escape
hell and go to heaven they know that
Anna will die due to starvation and
malnutrition but they don't care hearing
all this a shell-shocked lib decides to
relay all this information to the
Village Committee in the next scene she
calls a meeting of the council and
informs them of her findings however to
her dismay none of them believe her even
her partner sister Michael denies seeing
anything suspicious later Anna and her
parents are also called for a proper
questioning but as expected the cunning
parents deny feeding Anna anything other
than Mana from Heaven this results in
the continuation of the watch and Anna's
health keeps on deteriorating one day
she vomits and struggles to stay upright
a devastated lib tries to convince
Anna's mother to feed the little girl
and take her to a doctor but to no avail
why doesn't Anna just sneak in some
goddamn Oreos or something left with no
choice lib devises a plan to free Anna
and help her Escape From The Wretched
house she plots the whole thing with her
new lover William as he too is worried
for Anna the scene then cuts to the next
day where lib is preparing to take Anna
from her home after a while the entire
family goes outside to attend a mass and
taking this is the perfect opportunity
lib puts her plan into motion since she
knows that the little girl will not
agree to eat food or seek treatment from
a doctor lib starts talking to her in a
religious manner she tells her to
believe that Anna will die and a new
girl named Nan will take her place and
live on to be her Anna who is on the
verge of death smiles and agrees with
this approval lib carries her on her
back to a nearby well and tells her that
Anna is now free to go to heaven and
meet God the little girl smiles one last
time and closes her eyes shortly after
she wakes up reborn as Nan she seems to
have changed her personality as well and
is more helpful and happy than before
where's that poutine at she says
moreover when lib gives her some food
she eats it without any hesitation this
indicates that the little girl is now
ready to move on from her old religious
life after Anna is out of danger lib
leaves her there and heads to the
O'Donnell residence she then confidently
begins pouring kerosene all over Anna's
room before setting it on fire however
in the process she accidentally injures
her hands in no time the entire house is
set alight and lib Falls unconscious as
soon as she gets out following the
incident we see lib in front of the
committee members with severely burnt
arms and a rough face she hands them her
report diary which she is modified to
fake Anna's death when one of the
members asks what's happened lib replies
that she went inside the little girl's
room and saw her dead and in a State of
Shock she knocked over a burn lamp which
ultimately set the O'Donnell household
on fire unfortunately none of the
committee members are convinced with her
story and decide that she will remain in
the village until further notice they
also decide to not pair as she was
unsuccessful in solving the mystery
after all a few days passed by and the
lib is finally released from her
obligations and is free to travel back
to London before leaving sister Michael
undresses her wounds and treats her one
last time she tells lib that she had
left the mass early that day and she saw
what she believed was a vision of Anna
with an angel riding a horse in reality
she saw the little girl being taken away
by the journalist William sister Michael
then asks lib to promise her that Anna
has gone to a better place lib promises
and the scene cuts to her returning back
to London where's that horse William at
there she follows a piece of paper with
an address presumably given to her by
William shortly after she reaches the
place but doesn't find anyone nearby
suddenly she hears a knock from a window
into her surprise she sees Anna all
healthy and well she also reunites with
William and the three take a family
photo in the final scene they board a
ship to Sydney and all three of them
changed their names to make sure that
their past lives don't come back to
haunt them the movie ends with lib and
William happily looking at Anna stuffing
her little cheeks
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching